[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وهنا الشيشان
دوله تطغى هويتها الاسلاميه على انتمائها
العرقي نشات في صرام تاريخي مع روسيا
عقود طويله من الحروب الداميه مع الجار
العملاق السعي الى قدم هذا البلد الصغير
بجغرافيه والعنيد بحروبه لمقاومه المد
الروسي انتهى المشهد بان تحول البلد
الصغير الى جمهوريه تابعه للاتحاد الروسي
تدير جيشا بعقيده دينيه محافظه مواليه
لموسكو ويتهم بانه اداه خشنه للرئيس بوتين
لتنفيذ مهام خارجيه
ون سيف الجهاد ضد روسيا وتحولوا من الذ
اعدائها الى سلاح بيدها
لم يعرف المسلمون هنا في شمال القوقاز
السلام منذ القرن السابع عشر اذ كان
الصراع سائدا مع روسيا القيصريه التي ضمت
الشيشان رسميا اليها في حرب القوقاز عام
1870 وظل استقلال الشيشان حلما لا يتحقق
حتى في عهد الدوله البولشيغيه ثم الاتحاد
السوفيتي
بدايه تسعينيات القرن الماضي ومع انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي نفذ الضابط السابق في
الاستخبارات السوفيتيه جوهر انقلابا على
الحكومه الشيوعيه المحليه معلنا من جانب
واحد استقلال الشيشان
مرت ثلاث سنوات ثم بدات القوات الروسيه
غزو العاصمه جروسني عام
1994 لكن المقاومه الشيشانيه التي كانت
مدعومه بالمجاهدين القادمين من افغانستان
حاله دون تحقيق الروس ايا من اهدافهم قتل
مئه الف مسلم شيشاني في الحرب ونزح 400
الف اخرين ثم وقع الطرفان اتفاقيه لوقف
اطلاق النار واطويت صفحه حرب الشيشان
الاولى عام
1996 باستقلال غير محسوم بعدها ارتفعت
طموحات شيشانيين وصعد خطاب جديد يدعو
لتوحيد جمهوريات شمال القوقاز المسلمه تحت
كيان واحد وظهرت حركات جهاديه تحت قياده
شامل باساياف ولكن عام
1999 تغير كل شيء في روسيا بوصول رئيس
فلاديمير بوتين الى السلطه وقبل نهايه
العام ارسل قواته الى جروزني رافعا شعار
محاربه الارهاب لاستماله التاييد الغربي
حرب خلفت دمارا كبيرا بفعل الاله الروسيه
التي هدمت المدينه فوق ساكنيها وكبدت
الروس بالمقابل خسائر التاريخيه في العده
والعتاد ادرك بوتين ان سياسه الارض
المحروقه وحدها لا تكفي الى النصر فلجا
الى اشعال اقتتال كبير داخل فصائل
المجاهدين
[موسيقى]
هذا الرجل يدعى احمد حاج قديراف عمل مفتيا
لجمهوريه الشيشان وكان قياديا في الصف
الاول بين المجاهدين الى جانب باسايافو
خطاب لكنه اختار الانتقال الى معسكر بوتين
فجاه الامر الذي اصاب المقاومه في مقتل
خاصه بعد تسليمه مدينه غودرماس ثاني اكبر
مدن الشيشانيه للقوات الروسيه دون طلقه
رصاص واحده كما يتهم بافشاء اسرار رفاق
السلاح مثل بسياف وخطاب لتغتالهما موسكو
بعمليات منفرده ويحصل بالمقابل على قياده
سلطه محليه في الشيشان تتبع الكرمليل لم
تنطفئ جدوى المقاومه الشيشانيه سريعا فعام
2004 اغتيل قاديروف بهجوم واستمرت
العمليات المسلحه تلحق خسائر جسيمه بالروس
فضلا عن هجمات داخل الاراضي الروسيه وبعد
نحو عشره اع وام قضت روسيا على معظم
الحركات الانفصاليه الشيشانيه وتوقف
القتال على نطاق واسع ليعلن الكريم في
الخامس عشر من ابريل نيسان من عام 2009
نهايه العمليات العسكريه في الشيشان رسميا
[موسيقى]
اليوم تعيش جمهوريه الشيشان تحت قياده
الرئيس رمضان قاديروف من اجل الرئيس
السابق احمد قديروف الرئيس الابن الذي
عينه بوتين عام 2007 يوصف بانه فتى بوتين
المدلل يقدم نفسه رجل دين وزعيما سياسيا
وقائدا عسكريا للمهام الصعبه وفي الجانب
المظلم من شخصيته يتهم بتكميم افواه
الشيشانيين وقتل معارضين في الداخل
والاطلاع بدور حساس لتنفيذ اجنده روسيا
الخطيره في عده دول لا سيما في سوريا
واوكرانيا